There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
from March to test for ourselves.
This is the KimChi Chic
Beauty Teddy Kim palette
in the Boyfriend color story.
It's an eye-shadow and face palette.
I went in with the blush
and highlighter first,
and I loved them.
They were really buildable
and went on so smoothly.
Moving on to the eye shadow,
you do get a nice mix of mattes,
shimmers, and glitters.
I think all of these colors
work together really well.
I went in with a couple of mattes first,
and they blended great.
Then I played around with
these shimmers and glitters.
Again, these applied great.
They're super shiny and reflective,
but I did get fallout with the glitter,
so I recommend using a primer.
Overall, I was very
happy with this palette,
and another fun thing about it
is that it actually comes with stickers
so you can customize your little bear.
My bear definitely goes
to "Euphoria" high.
But, yes, I love this.
I can see this being
really good for travel,
although maybe a little bit hard to pack.
The Rose Inc Skin Enhance
luminous tinted serum
is one of the weirdest products
I've seen in a while.
It's basically a skin tint
with this serum-y base
that's filled with pigment beads
that give you some coverage.
They say to apply this with a brush
to break up and spread
those pigment beads,
so that's what I did.
I really went into this thinking
it was just going to look
like an oily mess on me,
but then I noticed how good
it was making my skin look.
The coverage is light,
but it's just enough that it gives this
my-skin-naturally-looks-like-this-with-no-effort
kind of look.
I typically hide any
imperfections on my face
with a more full-coverage foundation,
but this made my skin
look so smooth and dewy
that I didn't feel like I needed more.
But this product really shocked me,
not only in how good it looked
but also in how good it made me feel.
This is the ELF Cookies
'n Dreams lip gloss
in Cookie Dreams.
And, yes, it is a black lip gloss
with a bunch of pretty blue
and silver glitter throughout.
I tried this out on my bare lips first,
and I didn't love it
because you can see in the areas
where the gloss tends to pool a bit more,
it has this very obvious bluish-black tint
that looked a little odd on me.
But then I applied this
over my favorite lip liner,
and I immediately understood
why people liked this so much.
Oh, my God, it looked
incredible over lip liner.
It kind of gave the liner a deeper look
that just worked so well.
And the formula of the gloss itself
is actually really nice
for the $4 price point.
I'm definitely hanging on to this
to layer over other lip products.
I was so excited to try this
Huda Beauty Easy Bake loose baking
and setting powder in Cherry Blossom.
I had to get this baby version
because the full size
was completely sold out.
It's a baby pink setting powder
that's supposed to really
brighten up the under-eyes.
I just applied my concealer like normal
and went in with the little puff
that comes with it. This puff is nice,
but the shape was really annoying to use,
so I did use a brush
to get into the hard-to-reach spots.
This powder does have a
very strong floral scent
that was actually giving me a headache,
so I had to remove it after a few minutes.
It recommends that you
leave it on for five,
but I couldn't take it anymore. I'm sorry.
I did see a slight brightening effect,
but it wasn't blowing me away.
I could still see my dark circles
peeking through a bit. I do, however,
think that this is a nice powder formula.
It's really smoothing
and super-finely milled,
but they need to get rid of the scent.
Maybelline just dropped
its Super Stay Vinyl Ink
Longwear No-Budge Liquid Lipcolor.
This is a long-wearing lipstick
that's meant to stay shiny,
which really got my attention.
You have to shake it for
five seconds, then apply.
When I first started applying,
I got nervous because
it looked really patchy,
but I got full coverage
when I added another layer,
and it surprisingly felt
lightweight on the lips.
I kissed my hand to check for transfer,
and there definitely was some.
I did a test wearing my mask
and saw some transfer there too.
And then I took a sip of my drink
and saw minimal transfer there as well.
Even though I was
getting a little transfer
and most of the shine was gone,
the lipstick itself
still looked super bright
and it didn't move anywhere,
so I was happy with that.
This is the Dior Backstage
Flash Perfector concealer.
I think the main thing
that's special about this
is that it has a brush applicator
instead of a doe-foot applicator,
so that's supposed to
be easier to blend in.
I still had to use my sponge for blending,
but I did like how easy
application was with the brush,
although I wouldn't say it was any easier
than a regular doe-foot applicator.
The formula itself is really nice.
The coverage is more on the medium side,
but it covered enough.
I like this concealer,
but I wouldn't tell you
to go run and get it.
It's just a nice concealer
with a high-end name on it.
The Beauty Blender Power Pocket Puff
is basically a double-sided velour puff.
So the pink side is
for powder application,
and the tan side is for
blending the powder and makeup.
It does pick up a lot of product.
I tried to tap off as much as I could,
but it still deposited a lot of powder.
It is described as a tool you can use
for baking the under-eye area,
so maybe that's why.
The shape does make it easy to use,
and I liked how it has
this little strap on it
that can be used on either side.
After leaving the powder on for a bit,
I used the tan side to blend it in,
and it wasn't getting
rid of all the powder,
so I did use a brush
to dust off the excess.
I noticed that my under-eye area
looked really smooth, smoother than when
I set the area with my normal sponge.
The lines under my eyes
weren't as defined.
This is the new MAC MACStack mascara,
and it's supposed to be super volumizing,
which I love. What I don't love
is a plastic mascara
brush, which this has,
but I was still excited to try this.
When I first started applying,
I immediately hated the
feeling of the brush on my eye.
It's a little too spiky
for someone like me
with pretty sensitive eyes.
I noticed an instant lift
and volume with my lashes,
which are naturally pretty straight.
I did another coat and loved
how this made my lashes look.
They look long and full
without looking clumpy.
I don't know if I can
justify $28 for mascara,
but this one is so good.
I might have to splurge
on it every now and then.